the jurogan experience dude 12 years ago
today isn't that 13. you started this
thing i think it's 12. 2009 right
2009. yeah yeah 12. oh yeah yeah 12.
yeah i did that yesterday yeah
it seems like it would be
but no
i just rewatched a little bit of it the
other day so strange yeah and it's so
young-faced i know and skinnier
[Laughter]
both of us yeah yeah
12 [ __ ] years are we recording i
think we're recording yeah
oh we should get snowflakes we should
have had snowflakes on yeah we need
snowflakes can you uh do something i did
that one time we did this and i had to
do a lot of pre-set up stuff to get it
in there and we should actually i can
add them when they're not live yeah we
should have real snowflakes okay like
you have something that kind of covers
now
[Laughter]
bizarre right yeah
so bizarre
would you have that would you have ever
guessed that like
it would turn into this like how the
[ __ ] could i ever my mom's now watching
you for covet news and stuff like that
no it's pretty crazy my mom's like now a
listener of yours which she never used
to be but it started off with a guy from
cnn sanjay gupta yeah she's just like
i'm so angry and like
yeah i think a lot of people came on
board in that one that one backfired on
them yeah that i
it's no there's no way i could have
predicted it how the [ __ ] could anybody
predicted it like
we started off with like zero listeners
and just
not thinking it was going to be anything
other than just [ __ ] around
and then
somewhere along the line it just became
this
i and you know i always saw it
in the past like before we started this
like you anytime when you did morning
radio
you would always like you know usually
as a comedian you're in town you would
do like 10 minutes look at those look at
that
you're so skinny
i hate not having a beard look at that
weak upper lip
yeah but uh like like would go usually
as a comedian you'd go to a city and
you'd do morning radio usually you'd do
like a 15 minute like plug the shows
that you're in town for you always did
like three and a half hours you did the
whole show and it was always so fun and
we always remember talked about like you
need to get a radio show man yeah but i
was always like they'll never give me a
radio show
because then they would tell me what to
do and it would just be
so censored you know i could do censored
radio a couple days but after a while be
like what the [ __ ] why am i not talking
like i normally talk this is stupid
like you want to be able to talk on the
radio the same way you do with your
friends and it was never possible but
then when adam carolla left the radio
and went over and started doing a
podcast i think that was really like the
first
like i knew a pot that podcasts were a
thing i think i'd heard of them but no
one was doing them and then when adam
like literally just did a radio show on
the internet i was like oh
okay and then obviously it was like
anthony anthony doing live from the
compound was probably the biggest push
and tom green and tom green that's right
tom green yeah tom green had a whole
television show online
in like 2008 or seven it was like 2007.
it was it was definitely 2007 because
we went there for the carlos mancia
video oh that's right yeah and adam
carolla was still on the radio uh during
that time because i did his radio show i
think it's right
that's right
remember tom had like all those wires
running through his house and a room
filled with servers you and i were blown
away we were like what the [ __ ]
i even talked to those people because
they were located in denver the people
who did his thing i went and i talked to
them in denver and i don't know why i
wasn't into it they wanted to do
something but i don't know why
i was like
i'm just not feeling this i'm just i
don't know
because they they wanted to do a similar
thing to what they were doing with adam
and i was like oh
i don't know
just didn't
it's wrong timing
for whatever reason you know
you